The answer is 25.2.
The line of 25.2 + 0.67x = y.
This line over here is linear regression to the data.
Pictorially, this is the line just like this.
It might be hard to see as my shift of units, this is really 50 and this is 120.
When you work this out, this line hits the y axis at 25.2,
and it's steepness when it goes one step right, it goes 0.67 steps up vertically,
which is off the line.
We just did the following: we inspected a data sample with two dimensions,
and we saw it had massive outliers.
We removed the outliers using a very context-dependent method of just thresholding.
We calculated some basic statistics, such as the mean, the standard deviation, and the covariance.
Then we came to the meat of the unit.
We computed the correlation and the regression,
and those two things were the primary result of the step,
but they would not have been possible without the initial steps of cleaning up the data.
I hope we got those right.
If you did, you are a very capable statistician at this point.
This is a very typical question that arises in statistics
and getting it correct means you have a fairly deep understanding of something
really nontrivial that comes up in statistics. Congratulations.